you've never been in a like physical
altercation I know that you up that's
that's my vision you ever square up is
what I'm saying
yeah can I get me it up it doesn't
matter I in that situation I think I'm
so sensitive that I just like like I'll
try to punch them but I'll block I'm
gonna punch it but then I'll go higher
and do a belongs in the defense right
and then they punch me in the face
after I block after I put block so I'm
not I let my timings wrong wait do you
block while you punch no they'll punch
me then I'll block so punch the face
block kick but they're already gone cuz
I'm already in the ground I kick when
I'm on the ground yes I'm on my back
kicking but they're already laughing and
running away you know I mean I'm not a
fighter really I know yeah I told you
about that [ __ ] fight in high school
right when my brother's friend David
Oliver his older brother was a kind of a
band geek and I used to like his he used
to have like an apple and his hand on
the bus and I used to smack it out of
his hand oh you're the bully yeah I used
to [ __ ] like just throw rocks at his
face and he's a Somma nerd and one day
this guy goes
meet me at some like there's a with this
like empty lot by my house meet me at
that lot and he invited everyone in my
neighborhood and and my brother shows up
because my brother was backing me up and
there was like hundreds of kids there
and they form a circle and I go yeah I'm
like I'm gonna beat the [ __ ] out of this
guy right and I walk up to him and I
don't even I was gonna say like I had
some things I would say like
announcements yeah [ __ ] or what I don't
back into that yeah but as soon as I
opened my mouth he punched me in the
face and then I try and I do swings like
girl swings like this right then he
kicked me in the stomach I fell over
enough enough and then my mom pulled up
and she goes and my brother was so he
wouldn't talk to me for years Dave I was
he was a nerd like a band geek nerd he
beat the [ __ ] out of me
he deserved it and I ever since that I'm
like I'm not doing this anymore
fine I'm a [ __ ] I'm a weak you know
what I you know what I'll be honest with
you if I lived in a tribe with a bunch
of Indian I would be the gatherer don t
you can go hon you know I will make
moccasins you okay hell you and I would
make some [ __ ] good ass mom yes don't
you think yeah I think I'd collective
things the thread what do you get how do
you get make those I don't know how you
weather well we'll to ask our husbands
some of the leather you mean from that
your hunt please right then they [ __ ] us
in the ass just hear me out in this
scenario I know we're gatherers okay
right and we're next to each other and
when we look at each other we're getting
[ __ ] in the ass we cable I don't know
who would giggle I would cry yeah I
would cry because you were giggling no I
you were correct as I was giggling maybe
yeah yeah and then afterwards we have
the leather and then we make the
moccasins Wow
no okay thank you moccasins just for
yourselves or for the community
oh we do for the community for yeah
baskets whatever you guys need
we'll make basket right some baskets for
washings whatever agreeable you can go
[ __ ] you I'm not gonna get [ __ ] in the
ass
[Music]